ending the war in Ukraine is the best
way to ensure a global economic recovery
that's according to German Chancellor
Olaf Schultz who is in Bali today for
the two-day G20 meeting Ukraine has
loomed large and earlier today Mr
Schultz delivered those comments to a
group of world leaders other issues on
the German agenda include climate change
and the lessons of the covid-19 economic
recovery
now before the chancellor traveled to
Bali he visited Vietnam and Singapore
for a good reason
because German companies need to expand
their supply chains create more markets
and diversify its sources their sources
of raw materials to reduce dependence on
individual countries Mr Schultz said he
didn't mention China specifically but it
is clear he meant the production
Powerhouse many sectors of the German
economy are heavily dependent on China
here you can see Germany's direct
investment in Asia in 2010 direct
investments in China made up a third of
Germany's Investments on the continent
10 years later that had surged to almost
half
now in the same time frame investments
in South East Asian Nations decreased
the biggest countries of the 10 Nation
asean trade Bloc include Indonesia
Malaysia the Philippines Thailand and
Vietnam German investments in Japan have
also been falling down almost 50 percent
while investments in India a regional
giant stagnate it and it is the same
with South Korea before the G20 meeting
the leaders of the world's two largest
economies U.S President Biden and
China's leadership met on the sidelines
of the summit where they tried to set
what they called guard rails for future
conversations including red lines both
Nations wanted to adhere
all right for more let's bring in Tren
noyan she is with French investment
banknote Texas and Shirley she president
southeast Asia Australia and New Zealand
at chemicals firm evonik both to you
surely let me start with you
your company's website lists at least
eight production sites in mainland China
how do you expect this number to change
as the German government is urging
companies to focus on countries in Asia
that are not China
let me just explain a little bit about
our production sites in China yes we do
have numerous sites of production in
China but those products which was
produced to do a mainly serve the market
in China or in the Asia Pacific region
um without uh mentioning uh that we have
also the production site outside of
China almost at the same size within
Asia Pacific we still import quite a lot
of products from Germany to China
uh turn it over to you um Mr Schultz is
eyeing a Vietnam and Singapore
um for increased cooperation uh Vietnam
has been the preferred destination for
companies that are pursuing a China plus
one strategy what is it that they get
there
first I think both Vietnam and Singapore
have something that other countries
don't have but just the EU FTA right
with that the production of barriers to
um from terrorists but also um
facilitation investment and for Vietnam
it is next to China
um and and it has comparative wages it
has comparative uh um trade policy um
China does not have the EU FTA so
obviously if you want to invest in China
to capitalize on a Chinese market that's
perfectly fine however if you want to
um use that to export to other third
markets um for example the U.S like it's
increasingly challenging because of
tariffs and also as a result because of
this favorable advantage of Vietnam get
because of the geopolitical uh um uh the
Tailwinds a lot of investors are
increasing right not just
um we're talking about German but really
Mainland Chinese investors are investing
more because they want to be able to
from Vietnam access the European market
as well so so be Vietnam competitiveness
is it's a liberalization and it's a
neutral country uh for other countries
to operate and I think that increasingly
will be very attractive with Germany uh
surely uh over back to you um your
company does have protection sites in
Vietnam and in Singapore
um you say that those production sites
in China are mainly for the domestic
Market there all right fair enough but
are these places in Vietnam and
Singapore are going to get more business
now because Berlin would like that
I would say so yeah uh we we do have
quite a lot of discussion in terms of
putting more production sites in this
region I call asean uh we we do have
also a lot of production uh sites
already in this region especially in
Singapore uh in in our industry we need
also the total supply chain were
established when we put in a production
there so we basically more focused on in
um in in Singapore and in Thailand Yeah
so basically we also try to utilize this
diversification of the supply chain to
so serve the whole region of as a Asia
Pacific surely you mentioned uh that uh
the uh production sites you have in
China that they actually import steel
from Germany uh now that could become a
problem uh should International
International sanctions bite in the case
of a Chinese attack on on Taiwan how big
of a problem would that be for you
we use our Chinese production sites to
serve the domestic Market mainly what I
mentioned that was doing product from
Germany it's not the raw materials for
our production size in China but we we
still have a gap for the domestic Market
of the finished products which we are
still producing currently in Germany if
the worst scenario like what you just
mentioned that happened then for us it's
just a decision if we want to further
serve the market potential of the growth
in China by investing more in China or
we say that we just maintain the current
status
uh Tren uh back to you I mean Beijing
has become increasingly aggressive in
its rhetoric towards uh Taiwan it wants
to quote reunite Taiwan with China not
outruling a force how do you rate
contingency plans of companies that are
present in China
that is one that's hard to say when is
it going to happen whether it will
happen one thing we know for certain is
that the geopolitical risk are there and
you know even though President Biden and
president XI had a good meeting at G20
what's very clear if you look at the
actions uh um you know they have been
more aggressive Beyond just tariffs into
investment firms now on top of that one
of the risks Beyond geopolitical risk is
really about China itself China domestic
demand has been one of the strongest
fastest growing it's a huge Market too
big to ignore that said the suppression
of zero covet which everyone hopes will
be released uh highlights the fact that
if you have all your basket in the China
Market you need uh upsetting factors
right companies that have done well have
other markets that have grown um on top
of that there's a supply chain issue
right we just talk about geopolitical
but also again China has 20 global
market share for Germany China is very
important as a a place in itself to sell
products but also in terms of substitute
supply chain linkages because it Imports
a lot of products from China itself um
so so I think too much concentration
risk is never a good thing whether or
not Taiwan happens or not is is a big
question mark but we know for certain
that it's very clear that globally
everyone is hedging their best and it's
very good to diversify okay I have to
leave it there Trinity Texas and Shirley
she of evonik thanks to both of you